Okay, and the answer is memcached just throws away data
that is least recently used. So as you insert more and
more keys in the memcached. If there's not enough room, keys
that you haven't accessed in, in the longest amount of time
just get purged from the cache automatically. So the cache
automatically has the most recently accessed things. Let's talk about some
of these other answers. It doesn't throw an error. Now if
this was a database, it should throw an error because you
want your database. You, you rely on your database to store your
data and if it's not going to be the store, it should tell
you. It shouldn't just silently, you know, you know, accept new data
and throw away all data or something like that. But memcached it's
not an error to store too much data. It can, it can
only store so much. The next answer, throw away data that is
least frequently used. This commonly referred to as an LFU cache, least
frequently used. This is the common way of doing caches, but memcached
doesn't do it that way. They use what's called an LRU
cache, which you know, is least recently used. You know, least frequently
used implies some sort of notion of keeping track of how
many times each key is accessed. You know, it's a little bit
harder to implement than least recently used, which is just a
simple sort. You know, just throw the, throw the key add the
key to the front of the list. And the final answer
write the extra data to disk. As we said memcached is entirely
in memory. There are variations of memcached that write extra data
to disk. But, you know, writing to disk means, you know it's
a performance tradeoff. Writing to disk is slow, reading from disk
is slow. If you want to be writing data to disk, memcache probably
isn't the right solution for you You know you can use
a database or you can use some other piece of technology that's
you know, kind of splits the difference, you know, sacrifices a little
speed for a little bit more durability or space or what not.